some of you may not know this but the
world's largest living organism is
Australia we breathe in big out there
the biggest actually but because world
governments continue to ignore climate
change rising ocean temperatures are
killing the big girl we call her the GVR
the Great Barrier Reef in fact half of
the reef has been bleached to death
since 2016 so in order to get her the
same rights as every other ozzie most
importantly the right to life lad Bible
Australia have contacted the Australian
government to get a Great Barrier Reef
citizenship now Australian citizenship
interviews are notoriously difficult so
in an effort to make sure she passes on
offering her and those of you watching a
few tips on how ice the Australian
citizenship interview firstly open with
something like g'day this is a surefire
way to get the interviewer warmed up and
then secondly if they asked do you want
to become an Australian citizen so on
your answer should be in a year if they
ask you if you have any criminal
convictions your answer should be yeah
nah and if they want you to continue
with any further questioning generally
you just want to agree with what they're
saying and feel free to alternate
between to write and body oath and be a
cop or whatever okay and then once they
give you the thumbs up your little
Ripper will help seal the deal if you
get stuck though give me a shout know
vouch for you we look out for each other
that's what I was used to click the link
below and join us in getting the world's
largest living being the same rights
that every living creature on this
planet deserves
[Music]
you